you
okay this is the happy new year 2020
arena some 300 chess 55-minute
tournament Kovach opponent one yes
see the date but I am pretty sure it's
been a long time since we played last
okay my opponent moved I should move
okay or play nights I was and I was a
little tempted I must say to play e5
you
I'm not too familiar with this
is set up here
I rarely do I take I think I think
normally I just play here and allow the
capture okay
I'm more excited about trying to keep my
pawns
together just as I say that we have
black trying to break them up
undermining the e5 will take
okay I'm going to play without the
Queens I guess huh now I am up upon the
moment
let's see where the king goes first
after recall here that
this is not
increment
I just hanging onto the pond
maybe
I'm ready to push with check
Bishop g4 stuff you know I'm expecting
Bishop here this should be six stopping
this pawn from moving okay
let's go here
now let's go here
I want to get this maneuver in okay
let's let's stop g5
play a little faster my bishop on e4
well I don't know I want this in without
fear of night before let's go one step
maybe two now
I could have considered
this rook d6 move
while ago
I go here the night has to go where
back right got these covered
control
this would be a big blunder as long as
this king is opposite my bishop
now I'm a clear pawn up some space in a
huge pivot Square on d6
and I could slowly improve my King the
only piece not playing
oh that night jumping in it's not gonna
bother me
oh I get to push I get to push the king
away right
got to give up the night removing
d7 now
should be pretty clean from here
okay they resigned
back to tournament land and see we get
next 49er in here
still a lot of time to go so they never
quite managed to get that pond back
you know that was the beginning of
blacks troubles there
so let's see
and am blue
gambits is in there
okay
somebody anybody
it's a bit we'll wait here for this next
pairing
not too many are paused just noticed a
couple in the first page there we go
let's let's go with the d4 game
in jcf
jcf ting will we play three o's one O's
three Oh
here let's go with e4
Knight f3 and stop b5
let's also stop Bishop to g4 okay now we
go here
where do I want to go with the bishop
I guess here
not really sure
and I think they were ready to do that -
under my knee for
there I am on this can I get away with
taking that end up in a and
uncomfortable pin
alright I'll just kind of assume that
that's poison
wonderful mentality use that whenever
you can just assume it's poison
now that was me basically saying I don't
want to have to calculate so let's go
I'm maneuvering I'm trying to trying to
hop to a weekend square
get there you're going to cover it
I don't know how how great this approach
is but
in a try for
actually I've never even threatening to
dive in there for as long as this nights
there
Oh No could I do something like this
I won't mind being provoked you know
with the g5
if I take
let's try a chop
clean here I'm asking for trouble with
this night
huh
feel like I just want to give up upon
avoid any tactics maybe I get this on in
the end
I can't allow Knight takes bishop
dia was this with my knight on f4 in
this night here you see if I wanted to
do this to be to kick this knight next
but
not really happening huh
maybe we could try this move
I'm Way behind on the clock
yeah
we'll see
okay I did not expect that move
yeah that's
strong move
just going to be down upon soon I think
yeah
maybe not know I could take what my rook
can take on c4 and defend c2 after a
bunch of exchanges on d4
rook takes beat Oryx takes c4 I still
don't like my position because this
Knight is fantastic
but for the moment it is still balanced
material-wise I could see this guy fall
soon though
right
that pond is really fast
try and stop it
my king
but here I may need to maybe I should
have already maybe when the rook leaves
I have to sacrifice a rook to get rid of
a knight upon the Knights just too good
they're not even allowing me to do that
yeah uphill battle for sure
you
you
for Coronas everywhere
Wow
you
you
there are many good moves here this is
one of them like a basically resign
this is reasonable
you
who
got that pond
ten seconds
you
and down a lot of a lot of material here
oh and that's a good mate oh I wasn't
expecting that to be made it was made
though for sure my king was out of
squares ah had to do something different
there in that middle game for sure
that that was not how you should play
the white side against that setup there
that's for sure okay
peon next opponent
let's try u5
okay we have some catching up to do
we had a five a couple fours up there a
few fires
let's see I'll try and sneak this Mervin
how bad it is can I get away with it
night here night here
and it's probably wrong okay this move I
wasn't so concerned about
here
after chop-chop I don't want to see
Bishop age 6
not just there to defend
or to attack the best
- stop Bishop h6 what am i doing
playing some bad moves here couple bad
games now already this this was not a
wise choice
incorrect chess
I don't know how I complete development
oh man crying uncle
Challenge the night
mm-hmm
I don't think I could I could challenge
that I like this I could have challenged
the night with tonight before
could try it again
other opportunity now that the queen is
moved
I'm not sure really matters what Square
I go to
oh yeah it kind of did matter
that hits pretty hard now
Wow
can I go back in time here my f5
decision oh I don't like it
try this can't they get my king to
safety
it's the million-dollar question
okay
I guess here I mean if I played this
there's that or this okay I have this
square now for my queen a my slithering
away
am i safe yet it's so awful
this clown over here okay I'm moment to
breathe
there isn't a check here okay I at least
somehow got my King to safety
it wasn't looking pretty it still isn't
pretty here
take towards the center
even though this guy's now passed try to
target it
course it's going to push them
chop-chop there's a check but no good
follow up
I also have this move why didn't I
consider that
Oh there'd be a bishop check I'm not
winning
some material
so maybe a wise okay they're just taking
their
you
sneaky
and I'll take
here
I think I'll take with the king yeah
let's take with the king run right into
a fork
that won't be good
Time edge
sneaky check
I'm just gonna say it I was just
thinking I could take here whoa
now I could take with my king if Queen
takes Queen
I should be winning this pawn back
I should have been lost in the scam
ready to win the night in a couple
months
I'm getting the night
clean here up here
I could take care
very lucky
okay back to tournament let's not uh
let's not play a five you know
f-five
um
I was thinking like I've played f5 or
excuse me I've played f4 before so I've
played the F pawn advance
to bishops for let's just say on the
white side but playing it on the black
side which is by the way already a
little bit scary doing it
playing a tempo up but I was I was doing
at a tempo you know down there playing
with the black pieces that idea anyhow
let's get with the program Popovic
since round 1 has been and has gone out
at air
still some work to be done some prep
work for this advance I'm gonna go here
while this pawn is still alive so before
initiating this capture because I may
want to play see for let's see what this
Bishop does first I'm still gonna play
c4 even though it isn't hitting with
tempo I like this space let's secure my
Knight
and I'd like to go here like to be more
aggressive with my bishop
castles bishop
here and in the end this is a nice
um
acet this pawn on c4
hmm
I don't know if I want that night
I'll just centralize
keep this defended my queen is
just pulled my coin away from defending
this so now now I'm on this twice it
can't be defended but my opponent could
go on the offensive
counter attacking d5
we'll see ya
I'll take
you
and if that was really the right thing
to do
be a little bit careful here
now let's take a step up
last night's within checking distance so
ready to take and then take here so rook
here is a blunder I'm on this square as
well I think night here is necessary
hitting the bishop in defending situ so
this is a blunder so you could take the
defender of this Knight and I'm going to
take with the Queen instead of the rook
because I would like to now that I'm out
material
have a queen exchange let's put my
bishop on a secure square and now
contest the e-file
and things should be pretty clean from
here I'll take a step up I guess
I guess here
let's go here
chop-chop my queen now defends my base
point
case this queen tries to get active no
it's no biggie
oh just go here
change
step up here I can have my
and okay let's just take control over
this open file to open files
three but my bishop clogs up the deef
I'll throw in a check
transfer
and cleani to next
probably forces a clean exchange soon
to go there
and I continue
offering in exchange gotta go on the
corner
I get to go here
let's just go here first
I want that clean getting active
you
I'm on the rook no perpetual zmei Bishop
guards this
let's trying to get an F to now
basically pre-move it
on g2 can hit it again
[Music]
grab a phone
oh I could have played here
let's have my queen cover this diagonal
on my bishops gonna go somewhere else I
could have still played it
because I have f5 to meet the check but
it's trying to be extra careful I guess
now the king is running all right
the Queen no stalemates
no stalemates
all right pony resigned where are we at
here 75 or knowing there thought I saw
earlier the Ferrari yes the Ferrari is
in there fast and furious all berserk
okay
jcf again at
get him back
trying efore this time that are going
for a dragon
I almost plundered my night
all right
I jump in my gonna jump in
let's see d1 ignite here one day
let's protect my queen this may start to
be a threat
hitting the clean hitting this point
isn't this isn't this I think a winning
mo are
are they going to go for the exchange is
that what's happening in the end they
have this stuff but I have something
over here going on
let's take here first okay and after I
back up
to
let's say here let me just cover with
this dog and I'll cover my King how is
how is d6 defended
I don't see how now that this pawn is
pulled away
okay you're gonna go for a
counter-attack maybe let's grab this
pawn yeah let's offer Queen exchange
again no then I and then I will end up
in a skewer
all right let's defend my upon my guess
I was really tempted to play this move
you got here
trying to force a queen exchange I can
make life a lot easier
and go here
let's continue with this my base point
covered
continue harassing the clean
Bishop is excellent
very good piece
let's go
it's tough
let's go here not really a big fan of
this move but I'm gonna try it here and
then here I wanted to do something else
but it's not easy
you
this Queen should be able to Oh even
consider that that was a move
you
okay yeah
top
you have to take care
hmm
and I play actively
way down on the clock again
trying for six to break up the kingside
I can
bishop here with e6 maybe
King get the King later
you
no no oh I have to block my bishop
anyhow
that was silly let's just blundered my
bishop
now this one's again
poof so now in the end I'm just going to
be down upon very soon and all the base
points are covered
who this one's toast again
Wow
I have anything
just floundering here gotta get rid of
that bishop
Wow
you
oh I'm not even winning that pond ah no
this is far too easy for black far too
easy
Wow
you
ah man
oh I could resign this oh man their
queen was so active it's crazy
ah
hmm
I don't know I had a loss for words
there
well they were right to keep the Queens
on that's for sure I was I was up upon
they keep the Queen's on
sure that f5 move was very good
caused a lot of problems in my position
poof
all right let's keep going
there should be five
with a four
I got what I want a clamp on the
queenside
whoo okay I got the d6 pawn in this game
I wonder if I could do something with it
now now that I'm I'm up upon
it's a different story
here
queen is almost trapped
I might have to go into berserk mode try
and get a couple trees
you
and try
you
okay
I didn't play those last few moves very
good at all
move
throw in a check make sure I don't get
back rank mated
you
here here and then here
I cover this if they try to converge on
right now let's try for me
like we're going to get it
here
here here
and may soon
here there's this
and there is me okay
determine
we got the d6 pawn in that game too
see what the leader Ferrari is still
to the metal there
let's here we get next 85 in there nice
Popovic and ferrari are paired up the
ferrari berserk this one it's not
showing up that little icon the berserk
I come
and see who we get next ok MPO e
try c5 oh I just talking about berserk
now let's let's stick with regular
let's stick with regular see if we could
get a four this tournament
is that possible
get a square a nice ie6 if they capture
okay we'll try to be a pest here with
this pin
and try
pressure on each to
well let's castle
back up
you
I'm hinting at Queen c7 or even d6 now
on c3
[Music]
play in the center
not really threatening mate playing
Queen d6 let's go here
maybe I push know that I'm forgetting
the bishop is even is here
let's go here I know how annoying this
pin was to to white I want to put
pressure on e4 thinking about Knight f4
one way or the other this was my initial
ba here into f4 but Knight age 5 is now
available in to f4
so we'll see
Bishop's now defended so let's go in for
it
I don't have to take yeah I do the
night's covering f4
Knight f4
this bishop is not around to cover up
for okay let's return there are some
weaknesses here I don't have a light
square bishop that could take advantage
of it
but oh I could have captured on g3 oh
man oh man I got a time edge
now let's keep the Queen's on Oh
Knight takes g3 wasn't just the win of
upon I was landing a fort there
to get here maybe I could try for it
again when I be able to get a second
chance
it spawns in a pin now okay it's in a
pin it's in a pin Knight takes g3 do I
get a second chance no second chances
oh maybe queen g4 Knight f4 hang on I'm
looking for tricks I'm looking for
tricks I'm still looking for tricks
only this guy wasn't here
let's go here
that's a mistake this Knight takes
Knight whoa how many how many blunders
can one make
let's go here when in doubt go to c8 oh
no no I'm not down upon him I yeah I am
down upon
instead of being up in exchange and upon
I'm down upon mmm time edge that's all I
got
stare at the clock
get over here night
I don't know move upon dar square
control
all I can hope for let's play here
maybe I play here oh that was a big mess
okay I can't convert this ah they were
being
pre-movie
oh don't look back at that game okay we
see a pattern here two zero two two zero
two two I'm ready to fight Mike Tyson
isn't there a lot of twos and zeros in
that code let's go
less than 24 re the Furious one ah pehoe
Bukh you got Popovic there okay the
lemon
the controversial lemon another Sicilian
don't mouse slip Misha basics yes okay
I'm excited about 95 let's jump in
mmm
you
little baby step it
I want to go maybe C 3 C 3 d 4
now what's the plan
chop-chop-chop see three now
and D for possible space advantage her
Space Invader pond
here I could play there isn't this
maneuver anymore because I get to take
and I'm on the Queen
but what if what if what if only after
this move that move is played
okay okay
I guess if we miscalculate and it maybe
it's a miscalculating
moment tournament
down upon its close close there being
down upon Bishop here c4
Brook here is necessary
or care chap shop here Rupp d6 they're
allowing this why
Queen a four-hit black were there a
little tender on a week here the Queen
side
Castle let's take care our rook da
who is threatening me into
gotta go into a pre-bent losing a bunch
of pawns now
and I took in the wrong
or it should be this and then that
huh
really going to hurt me
yeah I guess I can't defend that for
third time if I take this part
or can I we're gonna try I'm going to
have some ugly pawn soon
very ugly pawns
and I win this Rikuo whoa whoa they
missed that lateral movement I get a
four did it happen
I gotta for lookout this is where I'm
dangerous
Ferrari slipped up
he's still in this berserk mode he
didn't preserve Popovic try f4
not blunder the a pond
you
don't hurt me here
let's let's go a little wild on the
kingside
I had an opportunity for g5
soon as g6 was played
that would have been that maybe would
have been a quick resigner maybe
maybe
let's go here
check okay
who
wasn't expecting that
I want this and then castle I want to
play g5 without night here
I had this so much earlier it's winning
on the spot okay space soon g5 by
bishops defended so there's no tricks
I got this covered
okay take or not
yeah I'll take once
taken twice though it's probably a trick
content with this file being half-opened
let's play this move I wouldn't mind
seeing it lock up no now we now we build
up over here I think
support for f5
playing and the only half open file
is this too silly maybe not
maybe not some sacrifices here
okay
let's dive in
I don't want to see this push so okay
let's play here
let's take this
I want to see this stuff
can this LightSquared bishop my poem is
playing very fast
very fast
okay he's slithering on in
I do something good here
huh
um I'm fearful of some sacrifice right
about now
let's take now that the night can't
recapture any more like a push the fork
Ricki I could take
and take care with check
and take care it's collapsing g5 next
threat
pressure on the night
okay
you
let's not drop a rock okay don't drop a
rock
you
his last couple moves
not a fan
grab that
with check this night is gone just do
not want to see a night around on f4 Oh
there's this fork in the end Wow
could have maybe just captured that
night
whereas the mate
check
missing anything every move every move I
have this feeling am I missing something
oh man
okay who is next under 12 so just a
couple more games
to maybe get second maybe that's this
big stretch
don't pair me up with this guy smack me
around again
wish I knew you ah this guy will beat me
up wish I knew you okay let's go
with ya
we have an Enzo Indian with Queen c2
Connect tonight's
for b6 Bishop d7
fish of d3 is threatening this poem this
knight is pinned okay let's try for
you
okay take
and
guess here
tough customer wish I knew you
let's go here I'm still in a an
uncomfortable pin
like to get here I can
okay
here maybe here
trying to get these guys rolling a bit
have this covered
you know
I think I want some peace off let me
dive in here
this is a square I can operate with
operate on the d5 square white is
preparing a central expansion I am on
seeds free so I mean maybe the knight
goes back home looking for this
we're going to find out
I may have to try
back here GFI okay they are capturing
still gonna shoot for f3
left three pressure here pawn push pawn
push I think is a nice move I don't want
it
bishop here
yeah or maybe better Bishop here
in the event
um yeah III really should have played
here actually I should yeah I should
keep this Square open for my night
I was you know my mentality there was
let's go here my mentality was let's
stop this pawn from moving as well
all right maybe have to play this first
do I go with this idea maybe
huh I could try to circle in like this
Bishop here kick my knight isn't done f6
anymore
so this
overprotect
this one here possibly
to go for a sacrifice
we over protect this
that idea
yeah they're provoking weaknesses want
to go all-in
Kalinka come back over here
oh no the Queen has a responsibility my
knight is restricting the Queen
that bishop back let's improve my King a
little bit I don't want to step up again
you
I'm on the rock
hmm
you
when I go for this
I'll take with the night night on this
square
you
of this square covered
dropping that pond for what reason
you
and that was a big Ponda to give up
there
at Bishop e4 if they take twice here
take
how my dark squares are so scary so weak
so so week
you
around this square if my night is
captured
you
oh I just hung my rook
oh just dropped my rook
you
you
oh wow I wasn't expecting to get that
one no way not on time not on position
not with how the earlier games were
going barely barely
whoo tough cookie
ninety-two are in here I think we're
just going to get one more
the podium will not be seen by me
shockwave
let's go at c5
tough middlegame there
I'm not super familiar with that
structure
86 was a nice destabilizing move
opponent played as otherwise I think I
play a six and
focus a bit more a bit easier on a king
side play I have to allocate my bishop
to defending b5
wouldn't have to
well let's see how they take 400 they're
taking like that it's a good thing I
didn't primo I'm take with the night
I want to have some quick pressure
against efore
and my night is supporting these two
moves I get the cleans off
huh
I push
I'll push
let's push and then go here
Oh
I'll just play if I first this is this
game gonna even get in there let's see
Bishop here first
at night is too good should maybe played
a f5 or I could have done without a 5
maybe it was necessary to play without a
5 yeah what am i doing
you
it's a very good move this is another
reason
I should have played f5
hmm
okay
oh boy
you
okay they're not taken there step up
this rook is my shield for my king maybe
this night is fantastic favorite piece
right now best piece in the position
their side
okay
clean up am i threatening this because I
do have something happening on g2 might
see a little windmill action
maybe
think this is serious
how do you defend against that
okay that's one way g3 I think may have
been another
and this is this is scary
I'm going to take with the bishop and
then play this move threatening e4
okay let's start with e4
I know that that was necessary
you
hmm
you
I mean let's go here I had in my mind
this manoeuvre King up
King up to e7 and then rook to g8 it's a
bit of mist a bit of a mysterious move
they're trying to lock up the King side
I guess
could play this whoa
Oh
oh did not see that ID at all
what's the imbalance here
a knight in a pond versus a rook
now this should be enough compensation
though
I have some nice activity here
I'm gonna secure that guy in maneuver my
night
it was a shock for sure okay
yep now can I take here now actually
where does the rook go
this guy doesn't go anywhere I just back
off if the rook gives a check yeah
looking for this think
yeah let's get let's get on with it
it's time to take that pawn know
no idea what the assessment is in this
ending I don't know that this one's
going to finish
yeah let's put the night here to one
king and unending if they try to get
material back and this pawn is really
fast what a shock I thought it was a
mouse lamp a quick takes rook no no
mouse slip didn't see that idea
it's just how it is
okay they're down on time
for the tournament final tally 56 37 34
top three you need to hit the 30s I got
to 22 the couple hiccups in there
against the same opponent who went
undefeated very nice performance 2568
only one draw
Ferrari nearly an all-out berserk 93
percent and these are the top pages
let's see everybody
it has been a while since I created a
tournament like this fun
you
all right
all 93 right there good games let me say
good games in the chat
good games are all right
you